are you pouring over every scene in
Yellowjackets trying to figure out what
the end game is well I did and I've got
you covered on the mysterious antler
Queen's identity all of the clever
foreshadowing leading up to Jackie's
final moments and Misty's cheeky little
one-liners that actually share a lot
more than you'd think let's talk about
the season 2 premiere Jackie is still
alive the sort of in Shauna's mind
there's a lot to unpack up there but
unfortunately there are no therapists in
the spooky Supernatural Canadian woods
these girls are stuck in the whole group
is very unhinged and instead of doing a
psychology profile on Shauna and how she
only slept with Jeff to essentially be
Jackie I'm gonna talk about the music
that plays as the credits role it's very
telling for what's to come every season
one song was meticulously picked by the
music supervisors Jen Malone and Whitney
pilzer to either Advance the plot or
give us some major hints this song
Cornflake Girl by Tori Amos is no
different the song specifically being
about a distinct type of Mutilation is
generally about girls who hurt other
girls there are cornflake girls and
raisin girls the Corn Flakes which would
be Shauna in this case are the ones who
hurt Shauna is pretty pissed that Jackie
out of all people ends up being a raisin
girl the girl is considered to be more
precious and rare than the Corn Flakes
so it seems like the theme of season 2
is going to be deciphering who in this
group are the Corn Flakes so I guess
we'll have to see now who is the
cannibalistic antler Queen in case
you're not familiar with who I'm
referring to I'm talking about the
masked person wearing deer antlers in
episode 1. their identity is one of the
show's Biggest Mysteries and something
the internet has gone into detective
mode to find out the possible antler
Queen for right now is definitely giving
taisa think about it she's the one
that's most likely to lead the group and
the one who has shown the most
animalistic Tendencies so far there was
also this perfectly time shot that seems
to be hinting at her possible identity
what do you think are we all reaching
and speaking of our favorite very
suspicious Queen let's talk about her
very creepy altars there's a theory
going around online that taisa's alters
have something to do with all of her
achievements as well as the fact that
she can't seem to remember making them
or how she specifically achieved these
things her biggest achievement so far is
her election win we got a close look at
her altar I can't see that poor dog head
in a few of the later episodes all of
this can sort of be traced back to a
conversation she had with Shauna about
how she feels disconnected from the
experiences of achieving all of these
major successes in her life not a single
one of those things felt
so every single one of these things
getting accepted into University Landing
a spot in a major film and of course her
election win could all be the result of
those creepy altars I mean the argument
is compelling but I think I'd rather be
below average in my field than put a
dog's head in my basement just saying
let's talk about Jackie the end of
Jackie more specifically there's a scene
where she's tightly wrapped up with a
blanket and ends up waking up later than
everyone else and saying that she feels
so cold yikes this could also be a bit
of a reach here but it's also a reminder
of when they first found the lake and
when Jackie jumps in saying oh
everything it's just creepy to think
about considering that's exactly how she
passes outside in the freezing cold
still talking about Jackie I'm not over
it there seems to be another moment
where her tragic end was foreshadowed
thanks
it's freezing out there this time by
taisa there's a moment where she's
arguing with the rest of the group
because she's trying to travel South to
find help while the rest of the girls
are averse to the plan taisa literally
says to them we're talking dying feels
like falling asleep Colt that's actually
creepily acute to what happened to
Jackie it seems easy to dismiss at the
time but if you take all of these little
Clues it's pretty clear the writers were
trying to tell us what was going to
happen to her right under our noses
after van is attacked by Wolves she
makes a comment about how she saw
something and from what I've learned
about this show there's not one line of
dialogue or like any small movement
that's not deliberate to the upcoming
plot this line was cause for an
investigation by someone on Reddit where
they noticed two moving Shadows standing
in between and around the rest of the
girls as they were standing over van
that's definitely odd the Shadows that
were noticed in that scene also seem to
be very similar to what Sami draws and
hangs up on his window it definitely
seems like something that hasn't been
fleshed out yet but I'm positive we're
going to be seeing more about it
throughout season two do you have any
theories about it this one was actually
pretty heartbreaking to watch not like
anything on the show is relatively easy
on an emotional level it was a little
suspicious that Shawna was the one
leading Jackie back into the cabin but
the moment you can safely start to
assume that Jackie is having a vision is
when Shauna says you're the best friend
I've ever had and it's a major callback
to right before the plane crash when
Jackie says the same thing to Shauna
you're the best friend I've ever had
though there's definitely a major debate
on how great a friends they were to one
another but anyway that is a huge
indication that this scene isn't
happening in real time but in Jackie's
mind as she drifts off into her final
moments we know Lottie has proven more
than once that she sees things that
others don't I'm not crazy one incident
being Laura Lee's demise it truly came
as a shock to the group when her plane
actually took off but what was more
surprising was the fact that it blew up
like in midair one interesting sleuth
pointed out that Lottie saw a vision of
a fire and bright light in the sky right
over Laura Lee's head though yeah that
could be interpreted as more on the
cryptic side Lottie did mention pretty
scary things like I had a dream last
night there was red smoke
and a river of blood it seems like she's
the one to pay a bit more attention to
if you're looking for clues in the
upcoming plot you already know this is
going to be about taisa when Simone and
Taissa were in a much healthier happier
place in their relationship Simone made
a joke about Sammy's room it's like
track this Crypt in there this was
before she actually stumbled across
tais's version of what could very well
be considered a crypt like mother like
son maybe either way it's most
definitely a cheeky little foreshadowing
of what's about to come for Simone okay
this might be an unpopular opinion but I
really love Misty is anyone with me on
that so we all know how the investigator
meets her end but did anyone notice how
long the shot was when her cigarettes
were taken out of the trash can if that
wasn't enough Misty also tells her that
those things will be the end of her
Misty being historically and maniacally
malicious couldn't help but give her a
little warning that she was about to
smoke some laced cigarettes obviously
super tragic for the investigator but
come on you can't help but appreciate
Misty's cheeky deviousness did you guys
notice a friendship necklace that gets
passed around the group apparently it
goes from girl to girl always ending up
on the one girl who meets a tragic end
this is something that never got
resolved in season one so I'm looking
forward to seeing where the necklace
ends up in season two and there's a
super creepy line that Nat's dad says in
her dream that also parallels a line
said by the equally creepy cabin guy in
Jackie's dying dream the cabin guy
welcomes Jackie by saying for you which
yeah totally creepy on its own but
that's doubled by the fact that Nat's
dad says to her it's been waiting for us
what is waiting there is no way that
this is a coincidence truly what is
actually coincidence in this show it
seems to be another clue about all of
the supernatural forces that are at work
in the forest again what are your
theories on this leave me every theory
in the comment section please and thanks
so did you catch all of those things
when you first watched it or did I just
blow your mind I really want to hear
your theories on the antler Queen your
thoughts on Jackie and Shauna's
relationship and if I'm not alone on my
love for the devious Misty and what's
your favorite Yellowjackets moment